"The Wall Street journal" is now reporting
that Wagner chief yevgeny prigozhin had originally
intended to capture two of Putin's top military
leaders as part of his March on Moscow and
when intelligence agents discovered the plot
prigozhin was forced to move up his time line.
Joining us with more on the real impact of
all of this, former CIA director and centcom
commander general David Petraeus.
Thank you for being here.
If these details check out that prigozhin
planned to kidnap two military leaders as
part of his rebellion and also what "The new
York Times" is reporting that a top Russian
commander knew of prigozhin's plan ahead of
time, what then do you make of Putin allowing
yevgeny prigozhin to escape to exile in Belarus?
[11:32:25 AM]
escape to exile in Belarus?
Does it add up?
>> Well, keep in mind that the Wagner group
is still a very useful tool in the foreign
policy arsenal of the Russian Federation.
In fact, the foreign minister came out yesterday
and said it would still be active in Mali
and the central African republic and elsewhere
in the African republic and Syria and so forth.
It has been very helpful to the Russian cause
in those areas and they don't have a replacement
for that yet.
It is also largely self-financing abroad.
We know now that some of the financing for
the actions in Russia and Ukraine were coming
from the Russian Federation, but the whole
affair is just nothing short of fantastic.
It reveals how desperate prigozhin had to
feel.
His contracts were cut off and that his soldiers
would have to sign contracts with the ministry
of defense and he was going to lose his army
and his Russian source of revenue and he was
so
[11:33:26 AM]
source of revenue and he was so desperate
that he would launch this fantastical expedition
to kidnap the minister of defense and the
chief of the general staff whom he'd been
criticizing, of course, publicly for many
months and then right before that, of course,
he also criticized the overall decision to
invade Ukraine and then the way in which the
war was being conducted.
So really an extraordinary moment and then
Putin, of course, disappears and he was awol
in the day of this operation.
He took the ride, unlike president zelenskyy
at the start of the war, this last invasion
and he has to now reassert himself.
He's got to show that he's still firmly in
charge.
He does allow prigozhin again to go to president
lukashenko in Belarus where again you'll sort
out, but he has an investigation launch against
prigozhin perhaps as leverage if he needs
it at some point in time and there is an extradition
treaty with Belarus.
[11:34:27 AM]
Belarus.
So again, we'll see how Putin is able to re-establish
himself now, but in the meantime, this weakens
the Russian forces on the battlefield at a
time when it appears that Ukraine is starting
to ground out some gains and still in the
early days and we still don't know where the
main effort is going to be.
I want to ask you on those fronts, the thing
that we haven't seen prigozhin in Belarus,
does that mean anything to you?
>> No, I think he's probably trying to figure
out what is his posture going to be going
forward?
Is he going to start criticizing the minister
of defense and the chief of the general staff.
I suspect not for a while, at least.
I think he realizes how close he came to again
ending up, you know, poked by an umbrella
or falling out of a window and he still needs
to be careful about both of those, so -- and
I'm sure that lukashenko has him a bit under
wraps as well and part of the deal was you
keep this guy quiet and keep him under control
and we'll sort out what
[11:35:28 AM]
control and we'll sort out what the future
is, keeping in mind again that the Wagner
group abroad is a useful tool for Russian
foreign policy.
>> I was just handed this because we have
new reporting coming in kind of getting to
what was going on behind the scenes, general,
I want to ask you about.
A European intelligence says there were hints
that Russian security services might have
had notice of the rebellion this weekend and
key to this, of what we were talking about
off the top, might have wanted it to succeed.
I'm kind of curious, when you hear that what
Putin should do now?
Does another military shake-up amongst the
ranks under Putin seem like that could be
in the offing right now?
>> Well, I don't think he wants to do this
immediately because it will do what prigozhin
had recommended be done which was to fire
the minister and fire the chief of the general
staff.
So I don't think he wants to do this in the
short term because it would seem to respond
to what prigozhin was -- was counseling,
[11:36:30 AM]
prigozhin was -- was counseling, but look,
no.
He's a student history.
He knows that history is unkind to Russian
leaders who lose wars.
He's got to try to figure out how to stabilize
the front lines in the face of this mounting
summer offensive by the Ukrainian forces that
have additional training and all kinds of
other combat support and service support elements.
So that's really got to be his focus.
How does he avoid losing this war noting that
the leaders who lost the ruso-japanese war
in World War I did not stick around after
that.
There may be people around the security services
and intelligence services who are starting
to think, you know, maybe we should consider
what might come after Putin.
>> Something, a thought that -- he's been,
what?
His grip on power has been 23 years.
A thought that probably has not crossed the
minds of many amongst his ranks for a very
long time if at all.
You were in Ukraine last month
[11:37:30 AM]
You were in Ukraine last month and there's
been a lot said about the counteroffensive
under way in Ukraine so far.
Do you have con fidence in the Ukrainian counteroffensive?
>> I am cautiously optimistic that the Ukrainian
forces are going to do what no force on either
side has done so far which is to put it all
together.
Tanks, infantry, artillery, engineers, air
defense, drones, good command and control
and follow-on forces right up behind the lead
elements so that when they culminate after
72 or 96 hours as is typically the case in
tough fighting, you can maintain the momentum
and they can crack the Russian lines.
We just don't know where that will be and
I'm not sure the Ukrainians do because in
probing attacks and reconnaissance in force
across the 600-mile front.
Think of the distances here and how tough
it is to put forces in
[11:38:31 AM]
how tough it is to put forces in position,
set the conditions as they say for the main
effort to be launched, and so it's hard to
say when that will come.
We know it's very tough.
Again, multiple belts of minefields, obstacles,
trenches, defense in depth and so forth, and
the Russians are doing this phase fairly competently,
but I do think at some point in time the Ukrainians
will break through and hopefully the morale
of the Russians has been damaged a bit by
this whole episode, as well because prigozhin
has said what a lot of people are thinking
that this is not going well.
It was probably a mistake and you know, who
wants to be the one that's the last to die
for this war that is not going well?
The Ukrainians know what they're fighting
for.
This is their war of Independence and the
Russians are much less certain about that.
>> General David Petraeus, it is